my students call me professor nehlo
because i prefer not to use mrs or
mister in my classroom i teach all
subjects as a first grade teacher but my
favorite moments are always when my
students ask about my queerness she
continues i was asked recently during a
podcast interview why i don't use mrs or
mr to refer to myself
and i asked her why i needed to she said
don't you think it'll be hard for
children to adjust my students are six
to seven years old and they're
steeped in the magic of curiosity my
students know about and have met my wife
at school they know i'm queer and the
turtles will call anybody out for
calling me mrs anything if only adults
adjust it as quickly and easily it may
save many of our lives but this is just
narcissism by another name this is a
kind of like sexualized narcissism
leaving aside mr and mrs is a non-binary
she goes by professor
teaching first grade students which is
which is something that like literally
anybody could teach first graders and
you and if you have first graders
yourself you probably should teach them
yourself